what's going on guys this is Rob and
with the season finale of agents of
shield being what it was it was kind of
nuts and so I figured a lot of you guys
probably have a whole lot of questions
for example what was the secret Gruber
what is the secret group that Coulson
and Skye reforming with the Terrigen
crystals being at the bottom of the
ocean business mean we're going to see
global terrigenesis and what in the hell
happened to Jemma Simmons so what I've
done is I've made this quick video to
basically try to answer these questions
as best I can I've basically gone
through every bit of information that we
have so far and I'm trying to organize
this in a way that I think it'll make
sense so I think what we should do here
start with the first question the group
that is being formed by Skye and Coulson
now this group is most likely going to
be the group called the secret warriors
the secret warriors were a group that
was created in Marvel Comics by Brian
Michael Bendis in 2008 during the events
of Secret Invasion and what had happened
here was that during the Secret Invasion
event the shape-shifting Scrolls the
eternal enemy of the Kree who had
basically begun replacing the entire
Earth's population with scroll
replicates now of course they were doing
this secretly no one really knew it was
happening but Nick Fury was the first
one to figure it out and so what
happened was Nick Fury basically
assembled a team of young I guess young
adults super-powered shield agents one
of whom was Daisy Johnson now where Nick
John I'm sorry Nick Fury was basically
the leader of this group Daisy Johnson
was like the second in command or she
was like the field commander for the
group of that makes any sense but she
was basically the one in charge directly
under Nick Fury now after the events of
age of Ultron as we know it appears as
though Nick Fury has basically
undertaken the role of being director of
shield again and so it looks like Agent
Coulson will most likely take the place
of being the head of the secret warriors
group and that will pretty much give
them a place to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because right now if
Nick Fury is back being and being in
being the director of shield there's
really no place for for Phil Coulson to
go but again at this point it's really
impossible to know in terms of what will
actually happen but it seems pretty
solid then that will be the case now the
second item on our list is whether or
not global terror Genesis will take
place with the Terrigen crystals that
are at the bottom of the ocean in truth
the answer to this question is is most
likely yes and there's actually a
precedent in Marvel Comics for this
happening
the infinity event when Black Bull the
king of the Inhumans detonated the
Terrigen bomb
the result was at the myth spread
throughout the entire world and so
basically we saw global terror Genesis
now what ended up happening here is that
a multitude of Inhumans from all over
the world began to go into the cocoon
phases and then emerge as Inhumans but
not everybody went to Attilan not
everybody went to become part of the
inhuman royal family in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe anybody who comes
into contact with these crystals dies
and so the question is are we going to
see some kind of global pandemic are we
going to see a huge reduction in the non
inhuman population than the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this is really a
question we don't have the answer to but
I would go as far as to say the given
what's been established so far the
answer is most likely yes that there are
going to be a litany of people who are
going to die but again we don't know
this off the top of our heads now the
final question on our list comes in the
form of what in the hell happened to
Jemma Simmons what is that rock what in
God's name is going on okay guys I
literally spent probably about six or
seven hours after the show went off I
got off skype I put music on I ignored
all distractions and I pored over every
bit of information I could possibly find
to find some variation or some instance
of what in the world this stone is in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe this giant
thing that turns to liquid and then
turns back into a solid form again
there's only a couple things that I've
come to an absolute conclusion on with
this thing in the model cinematic
universe the first thing is that it
changes its form whenever Inhumans are
present and it does it in about a
five-second window when I guess when
Gordon and Raina first show up these
stone weights about five seconds and
then it changes its form into the form
Ward has the three little holes on the
front and then you know holes dotted
elsewhere and then when we see that that
Bobby Morris or Bobby Morris when we see
that Mockingjay is a Mockingbird rather
is walking away
that its form is different because now
we're surrounded by humans this I think
is really interesting it really seems to
give some idea but aside from that we
don't know anything and the reason for
that is because Jeff Bell one of the
executive producers for the show during
an interview which I'll have a link in
the description he said that they're not
drawing on any comic related content for
this thing basically they made this up
for the TV
show there's nothing in the comics that
has anything to do with this and so that
makes sense well I couldn't find
anything so if this is really a red
herring if he's only just leading us on
and he's trying to knock us to straight
and there's something like this that
exists in the comics I don't know what
it is and I feel like I've looked over
everything so but the fact remains we
know that that the I guess the contract
of Elizabeth Henstridge the woman that
plays Jim Jemma Simmons her contract
hasn't expired and it hasn't ended so
she's alive where presumably she's alive
on the show but where she is and truth
is anybody's guess I have no idea so
with that being said I hope that
answered your own questions I hope that
uh kind of got you a little more into
what in the world is going on but again
this is a very confusing time so I'm
very anxious to see what happens when
the next season starts with that being
said I will catch you guys later peace